En Estados Unidos hay 60 000 personas
con marcapasos conectados a Internet.
Los desfibriladores le permiten a un médico a distancia
darle una descarga a un corazón
en caso de que el paciente lo necesite.
Pero si no lo necesita
y otra persona le da una descarga,
no es algo bueno.
Claro, iremos más allá del cuerpo humano.
Nos adentraremos en el nivel celular actual.
Hasta este momento, todas las tecnologías
de las que hablé están basadas en el silicio, unos y ceros,
pero hay otro sistema operativo:
el sistema operativo originario, el ADN.
Para los ciberpiratas, el ADN es solo otro sistema operativo
a ser vulnerado.
Es un gran desafío para ellos.
Ya hay mucha gente que trabaja para descifrar el software de la vida,
y mientras la mayoría lo hace por el bien de todos,
para ayudarnos,
otros no lo hacen así.
¿Cómo abusarán los criminales de esto?
Bueno, con la biología sintética pueden hacerse cosas muy ingeniosas.
Por ejemplo, predigo que pasaremos
de un mundo de drogas a base de hierbas
a uno sintético. ¿Para qué necesitamos las plantas?
Basta con tomar el código genético de la marihuana
o de las hojas de amapola o coca,
copiar y pegar los genes,
colocarlos en levadura,
tomar esa levadura
hacerla producir la cocaína
o marihuana, o cualquier droga.
El uso que le daremos a la levadura
en el futuro será muy interesante.
De hecho, podemos hacer pan y cerveza muy especiales
conforme avancemos en este próximo siglo.
El costo de secuenciar el genoma humano cae precipitadamente.
Seguía la Ley de Moore
pero en 2008 algo cambió.
Mejoró la tecnología
y ahora la secuenciación de ADN sigue un ritmo
cinco veces superior al de la Ley de Moore.
Eso tiene para nosotros consecuencias significativas.
Nos llevó 30 años pasar
de la computadora personal
al nivel de cibercrimen que tenemos hoy.
Pero viendo lo rápido que se desarrolla la biología,
y conociendo a los criminales y terroristas,
podemos llegar mucho más rápido
al biocrimen en el futuro.
Cualquiera podrá avanzar con facilidad
e imprimir su propio biovirus,
versiones mejoradas del ébola o el ántrax,
gripe en forma de arma.
Hace poco vimos el caso de unos investigadores
que obtuvieron un virus de la gripe aviar H5N1 más potente.
Ya tiene una tasa de mortalidad del 70%
si se lo contrae, pero es difícil de contraer.
Los ingenieros, haciendo pequeños
cambios genéticos,
pudieron hacer con eso un arma
para que sea más fácil de contraer
y mueran no miles de personas,
sino decenas de millones.
Ya ven, se puede avanzar y crear
nuevas pandemias; los investigadores que lo hicieron
estaban tan orgullosos de sus logros
que querían publicarlo abiertamente
para que todos pudieran verlo
y tener acceso a esta información.
Pero va más allá de eso.
El investigador del ADN, Andrew Hessel,
señaló muy acertadamente
que si uno puede usar el tratamiento del cáncer,
el tratamiento moderno del cáncer,
para atrapar una célula dejando al resto de las células
intactas,
entonces se puede atrapar cualquier célula de una persona.
El tratamiento personalizado del cáncer
es la otra cara de las bioarmas personalizadas,
lo que significa que se puede atacar a cada individuo
incluidas las personas de esta foto.
¿Cómo las protegeremos en el futuro?
¿Qué hacer? ¿Qué hacer con todo esto?
Eso me preguntan todo el tiempo.
Para mis seguidores en Twitter,
tuitearé la respuesta durante el día. (Risas)
En realidad, es más complejo que eso
y no hay milagros.
No tengo todas las respuestas,
pero sé algunas cosas.
A raíz del 11 de septiembre,
las mejores mentes en seguridad
aunaron sus innovaciones
y crearon esto para la seguridad.
Si esperan que la gente que creó esto los proteja
de la robopocalipsis que viene... (Risas)
... eh, habría que tener un plan alternativo. (Risas)
Por decir algo. Piensen en ello. (Aplausos)
Hoy la aplicación de la ley es un sistema cerrado.
Depende de cada nación, pero la amenaza es internacional.
No se mantiene el orden a escala mundial. Al menos hasta ahora.
Nuestras armas actuales, los guardias de frontera, las grandes puertas y las cercas
quedaron obsoletas en el nuevo mundo en que nos movemos.
¿Cómo podemos prepararnos para estas amenazas específicas,
como el ataque a un presidente o a un primer ministro?
Esta sería la respuesta natural del gobierno,
ocultar todos los jefes de gobierno
en burbujas herméticamente selladas.
Pero esto no va a funcionar.
El costo de una secuencia de ADN será insignificante.
Todo el mundo tendrá la suya en el futuro.
Así que puede haber una manera más radical de verlo.
¿Qué tal si tomáramos
el ADN del presidente, del rey o de la reina,
y se lo diéramos a unas centenas
de investigadores de confianza para
que estudien el ADN y hagan pruebas anti-penetración
para ayudar a nuestros dirigentes?
¿Y si se lo enviáramos a unos miles?
O, en forma polémica y no exenta de riesgos,
¿qué tal si lo hiciéramos de dominio público?
Así todos podríamos participar en la ayuda.
Ya hemos visto ejemplos de esto funcionando bien.
El proyecto que informa el crimen organizado y la corrupción
está integrado por periodistas y ciudadanos
que en colaboración voluntaria distribuida
informan qué hacen los dictadores y los terroristas
con los fondos públicos en el mundo.
En un caso más dramático,
lo hemos visto en México;
un país atormentado
por 50 000 asesinatos relacionados con drogas
en los últimos seis años.
Están matando tantas personas
que ni siquiera pueden darles sepultura
más que en tumbas sin nombre,
como esta en las afueras de Ciudad Juárez.
¿Qué podemos hacer al respecto? El gobierno ha sido ineficaz.
En México, los ciudadanos asumiendo gran riesgo,
luchan para construir una solución eficaz.
Están cartografiando colectivamente las actividades de los traficantes.
Nos demos cuenta o no,
estamos en los albores de una escalada armamentista;
una carrera armamentista entre personas
que usan la tecnología para el bien
y aquellas que la usan para el mal.
La amenaza es grave y el tiempo de actuar es ahora.
Puedo asegurarles que los terroristas y los criminales lo hacen.
Yo opino que
en vez de tener pequeñas fuerzas de élite
de agentes estatales altamente calificados
que nos protejan,
sería mucho mejor
contar con ciudadanos comunes
que aborden el problema como grupo
y vean qué pueden hacer.
Si todos hacemos nuestra parte
creo que estaremos en un espacio mucho mejor.
Las herramientas para cambiar el mundo
están en manos de todos.
Cómo usarlas no depende solo de mí,
depende de todos nosotros.
Esta era la tecnología que usaba con frecuencia
como oficial de policía.
Esta tecnología ha quedado obsoleta en el mundo actual.
No trasciende, no funciona a nivel mundial,
y, desde luego, no funciona en lo virtual.
Hemos visto cambios de paradigmas en el crimen y el terrorismo.
Se requiere un cambio hacia una forma más abierta
y una aplicación más participativa de la ley.
Por eso los invito a acompañarme.
La seguridad pública es demasiado importante como para dejarla a los profesionales.
Gracias. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)